S
TIME TO MAKE A CHANGE IN POLICY.
AND THAT'S "THE ANGLE."
JOINING ME NOW IS
STEPHEN MILLER, SENIOR ADVISOR
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP AND FOUNDER
OF AMERICAN FIRST LEGAL.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE HAVE MADE
ENOUGH OF THESE EXECUTIVE ORDERS
FROM BIDEN SEEKING THE WAY HE
CAN TO TRY TO FEDERALIZE
ELECTION.
WHAT ARE WE MISSING HERE ABOUT
THIS EXECUTIVE ORDER,
SPECIFICALLY FROM LAST MARCH?
>> WELCOME I THINK YOU'RE
COMPLETELY RIGHT.
IT WAS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
GOD RELATIVELY LITTLE ATTENTION
AT THE TIME.
USING THE FULL WEIGHT AND THE
MIGHT OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AGENCY BY AGENCY TO PUSH MAIL-IN
VOTING EVERYWHERE THEY CAN USING
EVERY TOOL AND RESOURCE THEY
CAN.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE TRYING
TO TAKE THE TACTICS USED BY
MARK ZUCKERBERG TO PRIVATIZE OUR
ELECTIONS TO ESTABLISH THESE
ANONYMOUS DROP BOXES WHERE WE
HAVE NOW SEEN MULES OR VOTE
TRAFFICKERS PUTTING IN THE
MASSIVE NUMBERS OF BALLOTS
UNVERIFIED, ANONYMOUS, UNKNOWN.
NOW THEY'RE TRYING TO TAKE THAT
AND MOVE IT INTO EVERY SINGLE
PART OF THE COUNTRY THAT THEY
CAN.
THAT WOULD MEAN THE END OF
ELECTION SECURITY FOREVER.
THAT'S A DIRECT ATTACK ON
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY BECAUSE
NOTHING IS MORE FUNDAMENTAL TO
DEMOCRACY THAN THE SECURITY AND
THE SANCTITY OF THE CITIZENS.
>> Laura: IDEA GETS DISTURBING
IN THAT THE EXECUTIVE ORDER, THE
SECTION I HIGHLIGHTED ABOUT
EMPOWERING THIRD-PARTY
ORGANIZATIONS TO PUSH THE
FILLING OUT OF THE BALLOTS IN
THE BALLOT REGISTRATION
APPLICATIONS AND SO FORTH AND
EXPLAINING TO PEOPLE WHAT THEY
NEED TO KNOW.
SUPPOSEDLY NONPARTISAN
INSTITUTIONS OR ORGANIZATIONS
DOING THAT.
I FOUND THAT TO BE VERY
DISTURBING.
>> WELL, THAT WAS EXACTLY THE
SCHEME.
THAT MARK ZUCKERBERG
PULLED OFF IN THE 2020 ELECTION
WHERE HE SPENT OVER $400 MILLION
WORKING TO ADMINISTER THE
ELECTIONS IN KEY DISTRICTS THAT
HAD A DEMOCRAT LEAN IN SWING
STATES, AND EVEN THOUGH IT WAS
DONE UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THE
"NONPARTISAN."
A FIVE OH 1C3, IT WAS EXPLICITLY
PARTISAN.
IT WAS TARGETED.
THE VOTER REGISTRATION AND
ENGAGEMENT AND DROP BOX EFFORTS
WERE ALL TARGETED IN KEY
DEMOCRAT STRONGHOLDS IN SWING
STATES.
SO, THEY ARE CLEARLY TRYING TO
USE THAT EXACT SAME SYSTEM THAT
MARK ZUCKERBERG USED AND
ENTRENCH IT EVEN FURTHER.
AND I WILL SAY, REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS MUST, MUST SUBPOENA
MARK ZUCKERBERG TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS IN THE NEXT
CONGRESS OF THE OTHER MAJORITY.
>> Laura: THE MEDIA IS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO UNDERMINE
CONFIDENCE IN OUR ELECTION OVERR
THE VOTER INTEGRITY LAW FAKERY
THEY ARE CALLING.
>> WE ARE IN A MOMENT WHERE NOT
POTENTIALLY REPUBLICANS WHO
AREN'T GOING TO TRUST THE
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM, IF WE HAVE A
2024 ELECTION, WHETHER IT IS
BEING SO MUCH -- SO MANY CHANGES
TO THE VOTING LAWS, DEMOCRATS
WILL NOT BELIEVE THE SYSTEM
EITHER.
THIS IS WHAT XI JINPING,
VLADIMIR PUTIN, THIS IS WHAT
THEY WANT.
>> Laura: I LOVE HOW SHE TRIES
TO TRY A MICRA TIE ON AUTOCRATS
WHEN THOSE SAME PEOPLE ARE
PROTECTING CHINA.
AS I SAID ON "THE ANGLE," THEY
WERE WORK TOGETHER.
>> HE'S THE ONE WHO INVENTED THE
DRIVER'S LICENSE I'M TOLD.
THE WHOLE NOTION THAT THERE IS
ANYTHING IMPROPER ABOUT ASKING
PEOPLE TO PRESENT AN I.D. BEFORE
THEY VOTE.
THIS IS THE MOST BASIC MINIMUM
BASELINE FOR ELECTION SECURITY.
EVERY SINGLE VOTER SHOULD NOT
ONLY HAVE TO PRESENT AN IDEA,
BUT THEY SHOULD ALSO HAVE TO
DEMONSTRATE TO BE A LAWFULLY
REGISTERED VOTER AND THAT THEY
ARE A CITIZEN OF THE COUNTRY.
YOU TALK ABOUT FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTIONS